javascript is essential to the modern
web but javascript does take time to
load parse and execute and this can make
your site slow let's see why when the
browser sees this script tag it asks
your server for a script named magic J s
your server sends magic J s to the
browser the browser then needs to
analyze the code that's called parsing
once the code has been parsed the
browser runs it
that's called executing all of this
loading parsing and executing takes time
and if your scripts are large or if you
use a lot of them that time adds up fast
meanwhile the browser is dealing with
all that javascript instead of
displaying content for the user let's
see how to avoid this problem here are
three levels of goodness good
don't let scripts block content as in
don't make the browser load parse and
execute scripts before visible content
loads better when you can load those
scripts while visible content is loading
and tell the browser it's okay to parse
and execute them later extreme when you
can make it so most scripts don't even
start to load until visible content is
complete first the first level of
goodness
don't let scripts block content when the
browser receives a script tag normally
it won't do anything else until it loads
parses and execute that script when that
script tag is in the head this happens
before it loads or shows anything in the
body in other words before it shows any
visible content the process the browser
uses to display visible content is
called rendering when a script blocks
rendering we say it's vendor blocking
let's look for render blocking scripts
in our site we open up dev tools and
then load up the site we click on
elements right near the top is the head
we click on the head to expand it and
that we've got five scripts right in the
head in the network tab you can see that
these scripts are render blocking look
at those five orange bars in the
waterfall those are scripts notice that
they load fully before images even start
to load now some scripts need to load in
the head sometimes jQuery does but most
scripts don't index is really small and
it looks to me like it should execute
early so let's copy this JavaScript
right into the HTML that saves the
requests let's leave jQuery where it is
to though it should be minified but we
really need to load that chat javascript
before a visible content or this
tracking script I don't think so so next
we'll take these other large scripts out
of the head and put them in the body
where should they go well why not put
them at the bottom wouldn't they load
last the bottom is good but
unfortunately even if you put scripts at
the bottom browsers will tend to load
them early anyway so let's go to our
second level of goodness using the async
and defer attributes async tells the
browser that the scripts can be executed
asynchronously this means while the
script is being fetched keep on looking
at the rest of HTML once the script
loads stop everything and execute it
the defer attribute does even more not
only does the browser keep on looking
HTML while loading the script but it
waits to execute the scripts until after
the documents been parsed I've just
added defer to every script on our site
this helps but neither defer nor async
changes the time when our scripts get
loaded you can see that they're loading
concurrently with visible content
delaying it if you truly want to load
scripts as late as possible use our
third extreme level of goodness when the
browser has finished loading the
resources on a page it fires the load
event now we're going to tell the
browser to wait to load scripts until
that happens here's how to do that with
jQuery the first line binds an event
handler to the load event that event
handler simply creates a new scripts and
append it to the Dom it's also not hard
to do without jQuery this is the same
thing we bind an event handler to the
load event that event handler creates a
new script and appends that to the Dom
look now at how much faster our content
displays that's because most of our
scripts load after visible contents
thanks for watching see you next time
and check out our other videos for more
tips to make your website even faster
you